wonder if we might start by you just
giving us a sense of what it is like to
be living in the Ukrainian Capital at
the moment we of course have seen in
recent times a number of rocket and
drone attacks targeting the capital
the last attacks what to receive for
Ukraine in the last couple of weeks
these Waters and heroes from beginning
the Russian government Putin explain
about Special Operation against
Ukrainian forces
of people they talking about the
Nationalist radical Specialists it's
everything propaganda right now they are
sending a lot of records and draws
to the cities and you see right now the
images from the center of cave was no
military
uh ways to live in civilians and
destroyed the buildings and kill and
kill the civilian people and also the
Russians try to destroy it right now
power plant stations in every city and
before the winter uh try to bring the
hot cows in in the families and the
citizens in our hometowns and try to
freezing people let them to be in the in
this winter period in winter time
without heating without electricity and
it's simple genocide of uh population
it's uh it doesn't have it it doesn't
have enough explanation of Russian
activities it's
senseless War but it's very simple same
after especially after worst activities
I tell to everyone put it need Ukraine
this country without ukrainians and
that's why right now try to let the
people in in the winter time without
electricity and heating it's genocide of
people
you must be very concerned then as as
Keith and indeed Ukraine per faces you
know perhaps it's it's most difficult
winter in 30 years that the Russians are
so targeting power stations and and
they're like I mean what preparations
have you and your colleagues made that
if the power goes off or for extended
periods in the capital that that you'll
still be able to cope
yes of course we calculate right now
many different scenarios also work this
scenario when all power station will be
destroyed and we have to deliver
services to our people uh to support the
people right now safety is main priority
for area citizens in our hometown and
also in uh for our country and that's
why I want to say thank you very much
for our partners uh we need under record
system and to defend the lives of uh our
towns or homes it's very important also
we calculate right now and uh by a lot
of elected generators and the mobile
heating station for the people if case
if we have a worst case scenario in in
Ukraine it's uh it definitely will be
not easy winter but we prepare for that
and Russians try to
bring this stabilization in our homeland
to try to bring depression to everyone
after the last records I talked to many
people people is angry
very angry in Russian and want to defend
our hometown and uh
nobody want to stay the need message to
Putin we never coming back to USSR we
see our future as part of European
family
I mean Mr Electrical you of course have
said in the past you know the war needs
to be won first but but the the overall
goal has to be the Reconstruction of
Ukraine so much of the country having
been so so horribly bombed uh by the
Russians indiscriminate carpet bombing
at times how does the International
Community go about helping uh Ukraine
with that process given you know we may
well see a lull in the violence as we
get deeper into winter but everyone
still expects Vladimir Putin to be
dangerous through those times and indeed
to come back enforce come this spring
foreign
from the beginning we have to stop this
war
and defer to win this war and we're
fighting right now to uh for our country
uh for defend our country it's very
important and yes of course after that
we have to rebuild the guard because
right now the whole infrastructure in
our hometown in our home countries every
dance is destroyed uh hundreds of
bridges
thousands of communities right now
without electricity without the normal
life it's actually uh this war destroyed
normal life for every ukrainians for
every family right now uh more than 8
million ukrainians refugees in Europe
it's a lot of people replaced inside
inside the country we care about
everyone we try to give services and
help to everyone but without help of our
partners will be pretty difficult to do
that
we very appreciate for help and right
now we prepare for years of course we
prepare for reconstruction we have we
developed together with our partners
plan for reconstruction but first of all
we have to stop the war and after that
we need definitely to rebuild the
country its main priority for us Ukraine
strong Ukraine successfully brain is
great answer is it the the best answer
for our friends and also the best answer
for our enemies and that's why we're
looking for success for Success it's
very important to be modern European
Democratic country Ukraine
and just one last question uh Mr
Klitschko we here in the United Kingdom
are on our our third prime minister in
almost as many months
um Rishi sunak has recently taken over
we know of course uh that Boris Johnson
was was highly praised by by Vladimir
zielinski I don't need you to talk about
the individuals involved but from a
Ukrainian perspective how much of an
assistance has the United Kingdom been
through this conflict
uh I many times I hundred times told I'm
repeat again uh thank you very much for
great briefing for support we never
forget your help and we see who real
friends of Ukraine uh it's very
important in this difficult critical
period of time if we see her real
friends of Ukraine if we never forget
that thank you for every families who
take your brain and refugees who help
Ukraine without your help is almost to
be impossible to survive uh and I hope
the new prime minister do it exactly the
same way because everyone have to
understand right now with the stand not
just Ukraine not just our families with
different defend right now the waters
the international battles and the main
Wallace human rights press the freedom
Democratic Wallace and we're fighting
for that and defending not just our
homeland we're defending also European
country because it's not a secret in in
Russia we have we listen the voices
they're talking about or to rebuild
Soviet Empire and be part of European
country just couple of years ago was the
part of Soviet Empire also the uh big
part of Germany was in Soviet Empire War
Mr Putin uh working as KGB agent many
years and that's why the main idea of
putting to rebuild Soviet Empire Ukraine
is very important puzzle in this this
Empire and we stop the Russians if we
don't stop them they go so far as so we
allowed to go and that's why it's very
important to support your brain uh Unity
around your brain is the key for peace
and stability in whole Europe